today's episode is brought to you by
future man all episodes now streaming
only on hulu josh excited to be talking
to you about your new show future man
it's kind of a combination of all of my
favorite things can you give us just a
little bit of a synopsis on what the
show is yes so it's from Seth Rogen and
Evan Goldberg and we have the writing
team sausage party so it's
family-oriented not at all it's it's
basically a show about a guy who's a
janitor by day and by night he loves
gaming and playing video games and he
beats this game that is unbeatable
and it turns out the game was sent from
the future as a device to try to find
the savior of all mankind
that's the last starfighter the exact
same plot as the movie what's a movie
then it's a big riff on like you know
The Last Starfighter quantum leap and
the show is very self-aware of those
things and we embrace all those
references and there's so many just
little movie Easter eggs throughout so
many Easter example it is like a mash-up
of all of my favorite things oh yeah a
lot of great 80s and sci-fi references
all throughout this series so with all
the time-travel stuff we were wondering
what would the movies that we loved the
franchise's that we loved be like in the
future or the past so what do you
envision for maybe Fast and the Furious
17 oh man I'm thinking a little bit like
Star Wars Episode one with the pod
racing
tell me about Fast and the Furious 25
there's no cars they're just running
there's a little bit of swimming and why
pizza what about Fast and the Furious
before there were cars if we went to the
past I think I'd do a riff on
Flintstones and I think that the rock
would probably win is God like the
biggest strongest legs what do you
envision for the 100th Star Wars
what's happening with the character
touring us yes you can make everything
you pitch starring you guys know it's
going to yeah I know it is in this world
right now and what's the pot we're on it
where I just see a porch we're having
lemonade after we've gone fly-fishing
we're on Tatooine fly-fishing on
Tatooine that say of it star wars
episode 100 fly-fishing on Tatooine
this show is co-created by Seth Rogen
among other people what kind of movie is
Seth Rogen gonna be making when he's
like 70 years old like Clint Eastwood's
age I don't know like they've really
like jumped into a lot of different
genres just in the past couple of years
and with this series like there really
is no ceiling into these genre and time
period that they can explore so set that
is 70s maybe he's gonna be doing like a
more of a like a black and white you
know like personal like you know
interiors sort of thing like once he
gets to be an elder statesman of the
industry what happens when 80 year olds
smoke weed oh yeah I think we already
know I mean Willie Nelson is their house
oh hell yeah what Seth Rogen's
directorial efforts what are his movies
gonna look like when he's 70 years old
fly-fishing yes what's Marvel phase 19
going to look like skip 19 that's
honestly honestly I think they'll skip
19 they'll go from 18 to 20 will the
will the Avengers all be like riding
rascal scooters or something yeah or
like mechanical horses oh I like that
yeah but they're made by Vespa okay sure
it's a Vespa mechanical horse serious
Vespa product placement in Marvel phase
1920 yeah they'll be called Italian
stallions Derek Oh get your Vespa yeah I
got it no I got it
Josh great talking to you love the show
congratulations thank you thank you
congrats on the show Hayley great
talking to you I just want to thank you
for making a super fun entertaining show
and you know thank you for all these
pitches I'm going to write them up and
sell them and not give you any credit
you're welcome
thanks to hulu for sponsoring this
episode all episodes of future man now
streaming only on Hulu